oh man so much to discuss with one of uh
one of our favorite guests in one of my
my good friends I love this guy good to
see you Eric thank you rich thanks for
having me Modern Family ninth season
ninth season just finished it going into
one more hour swan song one more season
passionately that's it well not
definitely but I think everybody kind of
thinks and assumes that that's what
we're contracted to do and I can't see
us going past ten seasons okay well it's
still as funny as ever it's such a great
cast it's it's so much fun and against
on tonight at 8:00 at 8:00 central 9:00
eastern time on ABC you are wearing
Kansas State pull over right now it
Wildcats on Wildcats coming up in 16
cat-on-cat actually had on cat action
yeah so how many bullets were you
sweating to you wanted to avoid the
become the first nine seed to lose to a
16 yeah that was rough I mean everybody
was you know I mean we immediately are a
Cinderella in the in the tournament in
the grand scheme of things and all of a
sudden it's like role reversal so you
know it was a great story for UMBC I
know those guys were tenacious and
played so tough it was an ugly game
let's be very honest we did not play
very well either they did I don't think
they played as well as they could have
played and I don't know we didn't play
as well as we could have played but I
was just happy to get out of there with
the win and moving on and they have one
of the greatest sports stories of all
time beating Virginia the way they did
it was incredible that was incredible
and and we were texting at that time
yeah when you and knew that you were
scouting also and that is it's nothing
but downside right nothing left outside
to go from a nine seed to take on a 16
seed like that well but you know what's
interesting my friend tweeted out is
that Kansas State is in the sweet 16
much like one seeds end up in the sweet
16 we beat a nine seed or an eight seed
and 16 seed so now we're in the where
and you're like the ones yeah you accept
where the 16 seed now you know you are
the sweet 16 taking on Kentucky yeah you
know which has got all these young kids
that don't even know anybody hopefully
that will be to our advantage
Dean Wade coming off hopefully Dean
Wade's gonna play he's that he's an
incredible player we've won these last
two games without him yes and the the
steadiness of Bruce Weber hopefully will
calm them down and we'll we'll slow the
Kentucky down enough and just be
consistent and play Kansas good Kansas
State basketball because we're
capable of playing really good
basketball we have a good team so
hopefully you look over the steering
wheel and you see a seven plane 11 seed
- yeah right yeah I mean it's nice it's
right I mean it's always all signed up
for something like this no right it's
all it's all there
sixteen seed is your second round
opponent a five seeded 16 seed that the
entire nation was ruining this by the
way you are you're you're I'm gonna read
out this tweet here that text pardon me
that you sent from the green room as I
was interviewing Troy Vincent the head
of NFL right talking him about the catch
rule hope he's still watching talking
about all this business of the of the
league note for importance for all 32
teams yes and then you wasn't preface
this by saying I am NOT a sour grapes
guy yeah and I believe you have to play
better football than the referees I 100%
agree with that playing sports growing
up it's no I'm not an excuse maker
having said that you said you text me
this photograph of who's the one who's
did you have triplet no no but Derek
Johnson is sacking clearly Marcus
Mariota the ball is completely loose
this is from a playoff game that the
Titans beat the Chiefs no high ball and
then you wrote back how about this rule
this is what you wanted me to ask for
Vincent the rule where you caused a
fumble and clearly recovered but the ref
who didn't even have the whistle and his
mouth says forward progress was stopped
okay and you left out the point then
then he goes in retires yeah and then
rides off onto this because under
trigger into the sunset it's like yeah
fumble recovered game would have been
over you that you do at least kick three
more points yeah right okay whatever
moving on I'm excited for next season it
doesn't matter the chips have to play
better football end of discussion and
every person in that locker room every
coach on that staff won't make it and
I'm not gonna make excuses of that's why
we're not in the playoffs so for
everybody out there saying get over it
and wants to you know mat me is what the
kids are saying now that's not what I'm
saying but that that clearly was an
officiating mistake and his last one at
that it is well that was a second of the
last one because there was one after
that who was who was it the game and
just oh my god
mm whatever okay moving on are you my
homes
what are your well being here the day
the news broke I texted you it was like
you think he knew that he was being
traded he was on yeah and he was he he
definitely knew it was coming yeah I'm
happy for Alex he got paid didn't he
disease aid yeah seriously he deserves
every opportunity he gets I appreciate
so much what a quarterback he was for
Kansas Kansas City and he's a good dude
he completely underrated in my opinion
completely disrespected in many ways in
my opinion by Kansas City folks some
sports people in Kansas City just didn't
appreciate what a great quarterback he
is so I hope he goes there obviously I
want the Chiefs to win the Super Bowl
but if he wins a Super Bowl
I'm happy for more concerned about which
one Pat Pat mahomes now getting the the
whole kit and kaboodle thrown on him
right now or Marcus Peters being sent
out I'm I'm more concerned with Pat
mahomes being the quarterback and not
being as ready as we would like him to
be or I would like him to be I don't I
mean I'm not no no I know he could be
like when so you never know he could
step if I start absolutely so I'm as
optimistic as a Chiefs fan as there ever
has been I think so I'm optimistic that
he's ready to go and and gonna be a
stellar quarterback because clearly he's
got the ass you know he's got he's got
the yes assets to be a great quarterback
I wish we had we just signed Chad Henne
I don't really know much about Chad
Henne to be honest where he comes from
good stock comes okay yeah we get it but
I like a real experienced veteran
quarterback yeah I wish we would have
gone after Jordy Nelson for that exact
reason because how great of a voice
would Jordy Nelson have been for Pat
mahomes do you think I don't know I
didn't even hear the Chiefs twitch you
know they didn't know I'm saying they
did but I think it would have been worth
first of all he would a lot of jerseys
Kansas State guy good business decision
yes and the experience that he would
have brought having played with with
with Aaron Rodgers right mr. back
shoulder throw right catching and very
similar to some Pat mahomes stuff hey
man
homes that's the guy that everybody
compares him to he's a stud for sure I'm
excited right him and cream hunt and
Spencer we're coming back you're not
excited okay but can you imagine Sammy
Watkins Tyree kill Travis Kelce and
Jordy Nelson yes
good luck defense well maybe maybe
they'll go ahead and and draft somebody
all right let's take a break in 60
seconds I want to talk for 45 minutes
just about Kansas City Chiefs well we're
gonna have some ability for you to we're
gonna play start bench cut with you on
many Kansas City guys we're gonna do
that and then last year you were here
just right around this time is fantastic
or you called in because you did not you
had a problem with the way that Chris
Brockman's clown makeup and bit like the
year before during the two years prior
awful back-to-back disgraceful then you
you clean things up in the operation
last year itself now at Brockman
Brockman is about to do it for a fourth
straight year and not just dependent on
Kansas State losing though ah here's the
thing is that I need a lot we'll explain
that one in 60 seconds we're back with
the modern families Eric Stonestreet
here on the Rich Eisen
[Music]
Erick's don't strap back here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so Chris Brockman
will wear clown makeup for fourth year
in a row on Saul I've never even
addressed the idea that some wearing
clown makeup is some sort of punishment
that in itself is disrespectful like you
should be honored to put on clown makeup
honestly clowns bring joy to the world
go ahead
as do i oh my showing the last three
years now the one on the right is what
you yes you counseled last year you like
that right i do i gave it the stone
street blue checkmark yes looking at it
now it's still a little miny
which is fine but it's it's good I have
made my recommendation for this show but
those first two years are it's not
that's not okay for clown makeup for
clown makeup yes it's not okay I mean
this is what gives clowns a bad name is
that makeup that design wrong with I'm
not saying the application whoever did
it I'm not it's okay mad at you or
anything like that but just this notion
that that is what a clown is is awful
red red makeup around the eyes red
makeup above the lower lip is like a No
okay and do that alright so you have a
specific because it Chris what is what
is the partridge in a pear tree
seventeen partly to avoid the the what
the the honor of wearing clown makeup
so I need Kansas State to beat Kentucky
check
I need let's see Loyola Chicago to win
sister Janice sister Jesus yeah yeah
check I need Texas A&M to win big twelve
check I need Gonzaga to win against
Texas A&M as SEC yeah that's alright and
then are you West Virginia Purdue Bob
Huggins Clemson and Syracuse a
suggestion yeah to switch it up for you
this year I want you to be if that
happens I want you to be in a goosed
clown commonly referred to like is what
most people think of as a Ringling
circus clown okay Lou Jacobs is perhaps
one of the most famous circus clowns of
time Lou Jacobs style make up a goose
clown what Fizbo is on Modern Family
gusta clown oh is that what we're seeing
on this night well that's a terrible
representation of it who brought that up
no sir I said Google Ringling a goose
the Ringling that's like a bonus that's
a not a good version this is like the
catch rule I'm so confused what's in it
bring up jingling a goose clown and I
will show you
that's like clown and not a clown that's
you know like that is you got a clip
process that to me is clip art that is
somebody that's today we need a costume
person in clown we need makeup and they
just did that you need to bring up
Ringling Brothers Agusta clowns alright
are you ready to play start bench cut
here so yes okay we've got we've got a
whole bunch of start bench cuts for Eric
Stonestreet of Modern Family just
taunting me it was it was Kansas on
Kansas State photograph can't say it was
in quality defensive position we gotta
you gotta appreciate Kansas basketball
though I mean I know a lot of Kansas
State fans are gonna be like I can't
believe you're saying that but you got
to respect what they've done they're
incredible I know but they're I think
they're I don't think they're in trouble
against Clemson big-time big-time I
think you might that must be I would
give you great pride to outlast Kansas
I'm all big 12 once the tournament
happens ok you ready for start bench cut
yep all right first up we go in Kansas
City Sports icon first up right is that
what we're doing folks start bench cut
okay bill Schneider
George Brett and Christian Okoye oh you
guys you're using my list against me yes
okay well are we talking just in playing
sports cuz I'm cutting bill if we're
talking about because he would break his
all of his feeble bones no no just okay
just in terms of okay I think on all
right I'm starting bill Schneider I'm
benching George Brett and I'm cutting
Christian aquinnah make these decisions
now Akoya is your favorite
one of my favorites of all time and why
is that because he was a discus thrower
there I am with him at a Dodger Stadium
as a Dodger Stadium
Oh God Kansas City people are gonna be
like you see it here it comes Eisen
but I saw him at Dodger Stadium and I
was like I'm pretty sure that's
Christian Okoye there sure enough it was
but I was a fan of his because he was a
discus thrower and I used to watch
discus videos when I went to Nebraska
track and field camp and I knew who he
was before the Chiefs drafted him right
so I got my picture with him finally and
you you threw discus in high school
yourself yeah in junior college until I
hurt my shoulder but I wasn't gonna be
good and we've got it video we got a
photograph of that oh yeah Arkansas god
that's when everything was okay look at
that body look at you man oh look at
that look at my man my legs look at you
just go through their days yeah anyway
Christian Okoye okay here's the next one
ball on the 1-yard line who gets the
rock priest Holmes Larry Johnson or
Kareem Han start bench cut we took a koi
out cuz we just used him okay start
bench cut ball on the 1-yard line cut
larry johnson dart priest Holmes bench
cream hunt it's only one year in the
league priest Holmes was proven but
Larry Johnson gets I love Larry Johnson
I know but well you if you would have
put Marcus Allen up there I would have
taken Marcus Allen okay all right very
good
next one best Kansas City barbecue ribs
brisket pulled pork
Oh well whoever came up with that list I
have a real problem with brisket and
pulled pork is not anything I would say
Kansas City is known for okay I would
say rib but anyway I'll go ribs start
ribs yeah cut pulled pork and bench
brisket okay well what would have been a
better start bench ribs burnt ends okay
and maybe sausage or chicken okay so
ribs would have still been the story it
still would have been the ribs ribs in
Kansas City I think okay that's barbecue
side item okay
cornbread mac and cheese beans barbecue
beans
okay well beans on that list because
again you
we're geographically off on this mystery
guy's cornbread is not anything and kid
wonder white bread is what you want in
Kansas City so beans cut cut coal cut
cornbread what was the other one mac and
cheese mac and cheese is will bench that
okay this should have been coleslaw
beans and fries I cannot read the last
one because if you're a pissed about the
way that the barbecue started let's
start bench cut for Eric Stonestreet
what most iconic clown Oh
Krusty just put John Wayne Gacy up there
walk out of this studio you wanted to
didn't you bench and crusty cutting
penny wise unbelievable unbelievable
okay what do you have coming today into
the show well let's feels free to stay
if you want let's stick around one more
oh my god oh my gosh I'm glad she's not
leaving another commercial break to
squeeze out another start bench caught
Eric Stonestreet here on the Rich Eisen
show are back with more animal
oh man this is so much fun Eric
Stonestreet they're gonna close the show
out with us let's check on the up hole
question that was brought to you by true
car car shopping can be confusing with
terms like dealer price list price and
invoice true car will show you what
other people paid for the car that you
want so you can recognize a good price
when you're ready to buy a new or used
car visit true car to ensure more
confident
car buying experience what's the poll
question results as we close up shop
here on this Wednesday show talking
about the new AAF Eric have you heard
about this new severing League that uh
that was announced potentially to visit
McMahon no it's gonna go up against the
XFL oh yeah yeah so they have a bunch of
random new rules so which rule would you
like to see in the NFL right now 59% no
TV timeouts 17% 30-second play clock no
extra points 11% onside kick fourth and
ten from the thirty five nine percent no
kickoffs four percent yeah yeah they're
gonna have where is this gonna be played
it's probably here in Los Angeles in
seven other cities across the country
that's cool I'm happy for guys to
continue getting to play foot yeah and
they're gonna do it they're gonna start
it I think the Thursday after the Super
Bowl next year like how many games a
game I think ten they're still figuring
out I mean they're you think about how
many guys that are so talented that play
college football that I mean the NFL is
you know very difficult to make it right
so there's still that the idea that
there could be an avenue like there is
in baseball there's so many avenues for
baseball players to continue playing by
great baseball cuz the average NFL
career last four years so I mean it's
it's it's there's an opportunity maybe
from one to go to the other you never
know but I like the idea that they're
the if you're going to have no kickoffs
they said instead of an onside kick they
would give you a chance to if you score
to keep the ball fourth and ten from
your own 35 if you make it you keep the
ball if not the other team gets it like
make kind of like make it take it like
pretty much I thought you were gonna say
no kick off but a guy just drops back
and throws the ball no I think dude
you're just gonna be first intern from
your own 25 each time coughs no kickoffs
I'll watch one game of that it's so good
show today with Martellus Bennett Joe
Thomas Scott Hamilton Troy Vincent in
you Eric Stonestreet is there a secret
life of pets too in the in the
yeah well it's almost in the can we're
recording it now yeah your daughter
loves it telling you that's why we
discussed it last week when you called
in from Napa it's just you know my Duke
it's a killer it's a killer I've been on
two weeks in a row it's time I feel like
I can't come back now for at least a
year and a half oh right there's no
born-on date with that with an
appearance here this is so fun you get
to view this though I'm a blessed man
yeah I'm a blessed man tomorrow I guess
with two s bombs from Martellus Bennett
yes I did one and one from Eric
we were only preparing for Timothy
Olyphant to stop by oh I love Tim
Timothy I just did what I hate actors do
we called him Timothy and then I called
him Tim like I know him way better or
something
Timothy oh man I can't believe I just
did that but I love that guy he's coming
in tomorrow and so is Adam rip on we'll
talk some more ice skating Candace
Parker Josh Rosen will be and I was on
the show with Joe Thomas today by the
way like what do you mean well he was
that was a huge deal to me
the fact that Joe Thomas was aren't
called into your show today which is
cool cuz I think he's the greatest now I
know you're an offensive line junkie
yeah you are yeah cuz when I when I when
I was calling information to use against
you and start bench cut yeah asking you
who's your favorite Kansas City chief of
all time by the way Brockman tell him
who you predicted his answer would be
for his greatest can't City chief of all
time or should I call you and and also
the offensive lineman as well oh yeah
John all tojon all yeah because I know
you got a general jersey yeah I have a
general jersey it's the only Jersey of
Chiefs I have but now you know I'm so
stoked about our offensive line in
Kansas City now I think it's really good
we have we have a couple great guys
there a few guys yeah I don't blame me
for one and Jordy - that would have been
a need oh we would had to do some
financial cuts for sure but the idea
that we could have brought a Kansas guy
home to Kansas City Missouri right
we would have they would have sold so
many jerseys and he would have been a
great steady measured guy for Patrick
mahomes what do you think of the catch
rule change I love it I'm excited again
let's talk about that former progress
rule
commissioner and you know well you can
do that right now can't you can't you
text can't you go up the flowchart with
it with the Commission maybe maybe not
yes you can he's a big camp coach camp
fire he is Roger Goodell I love
Roger he is I he's hilarious and I wish
he would show his sense of humor as much
more because he is truly a funny funny
dude
he loves busting my chops now people
said balls but then I talked myself out
of it because I didn't know if I could
say that but then you said it anyway
yeah but then I said okay well we're
just talking about that could what's a
catch not a catch anyway that's all good
yeah we've said that about we said about
that about Roger many many times who do
you want the Jesse draft I'm going up
right now cuz it's three it's gonna be
either the guy sitting in that chair on
Friday or Baker Mayfield
I love Baker I would love guy I will
make my decision after Friday's show I
think Baker has a personality to deal in
New York too I do too and so does Josh
Rosen yeah I think so too yeah a
thousand for CBS Josh Rosen cuz when I
see him on TV he does not look like he's
big he's not not thick but he's tall
he's like six thirty six
oh he's a big tall good good good 64 he
is it's for it and I'll be here on
Friday with the showrunner of billions
Brian compliment also the man who great
show yeah exactly
thank you for coming on thanks man thank
you this is so fun we'll see you next
week here no well I would if you can
yeah people can just you know whatever
and Chris Brockman you're you you will
be and I'll be watching auguste
individual goose yeah in a couple of
Tuesday's I'm gonna go shopping and
we'll film it so any questions content
I'm available
I'm I'm available via text through rich
I think you got it almost Kevin Bacon
like connection the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience